ما سيفعله الصاروخ هو أنه سوف يطير فوق
الدبابة ثم ينخفض ​​إلى أقل من 90 درجة
مباشرة في الجزء العلوي من البرج
الذي لا يتمتع بحماية جيدة، والذي تم
وضعه 100
مرة على مدار الـ 14 شهرًا الماضية،
وتستخدم أوكرانيا الأسلحة الغربية لإحداث تأثير مدمر على
روسيا وفقًا لأحدها.  فقدت التقديرات الأخيرة ما يصل
إلى نصف أسطول الدبابات التشغيلي
في هذه الحرب.
ويقول المسؤولون الغربيون الآن إن روسيا
نفضت الغبار عن نماذج أقدم بكثير لتحل محلها، وقد تم
استخدام هذا المدفع في مدمرة الدبابات Su-100
في عام 1944، لذا فهو
مدفع من الحرب العالمية الثانية بما في ذلك  تم بناء -55 لأول مرة
في الأربعينيات من القرن الماضي، وهي موجودة الآن
في متحف الحرب الإمبراطوري خارج
كامبريدج.
صور الأقمار الصناعية لمنشأة تخزين
في أقصى شرق روسيا تظهر العشرات من
الدبابات التي تمت إزالتها في العام الماضي.
تظهر هذه الصورة الدبابة t-55 في نفس
المنشأة
ظهر مقطع فيديو لأول مرة في شهر مارس
يُظهر أيضًا حمولة قطار أثناء التحرك،
ويُقال إن
وزارة الدفاع الروسية لم
تؤكد نشرها في مكان ما في روسيا، ولكن في
الأسابيع الأخيرة، بدأ المدونون الروس ذوو العلاقات الجيدة في
عرض دبابات T-55 في
الأراضي التي تحتلها روسيا في  أوكرانيا
هناك الكثير منها تم
تصنيعها أكثر من مائة ألف
إجمالاً والأجزاء
والأجزاء الميكانيكية الأساسية كلها قابلة للتبديل،
لذلك سيكون هناك مخزون كبير من
هذه الدبابات
T-55 التي كانت عنصرًا مركزيًا في
ترسانة الاتحاد السوفيتي في الحرب الباردة التي ساعدت في سحق
الانتفاضات الديمقراطية.  في أوروبا الشرقية،
المجر في عام 1956، في ربيع براغ
بعد 12 عامًا،
ولكن بحلول الوقت الذي استخدمها العراق في
حرب الخليج في أوائل التسعينيات، قمنا بإخراج
14 دبابة من طراز T-55 كانت قد
خرجت بالفعل وتقوم الآن بتزويد أوكرانيا على ما
أعتقد.  مع الأسلحة الغربية،
يجب على الروس أن يتوقعوا خسائر فادحة للغاية
إذا كانوا يتوقعون المضي
قدمًا باستخدام هذا النوع من الأنظمة، كما
يقول الخبراء وراء
الدعاية الرسمية، لا تستطيع روسيا بناء
أسلحة جديدة بالسرعة الكافية.
العقوبات الغربية التي تستهدف في المقام الأول
وصول روسيا إلى الأجزاء التقنية الأعلى
للأسلحة جعلتها كذلك.  من الصعب جدًا
عليهم تصنيع معدات أكثر حداثة،
ودبابات أقدم وأبسط مثل هذه، حيث
توفر الآلاف منها التي تجلس في المخازن بديلاً،
ولكن هذا مقابل دبابة ليوبارد 2 أو
منافس، ماذا يحدث إذا كان
الاشتباك دبابة واحد لواحد على
مسافة معقولة  سيخسر هذا في كل
مرة ولكن في البيئات المشجرة أو المبنية الأقرب، يكون
هذا كافيًا، ومن
الأسهل أيضًا الحفاظ على
الأنظمة الأحدث والتدريب عليها، وهي ميزة
للقوات المعبأة في روسيا. حفرة أكبر. قم بوضع
الدبابة في الحفرة حتى تتمكن من رؤية
البرج فقط.  وبعد ذلك يمكن استخدام ذلك
للدفاع عن خط المواجهة ضد الهجوم المضاد الذي تقوم به
روسيا الآن بكل ما
لديها بينما تستعد أوكرانيا لما
قد يكون أكبر هجوم مضاد لها حتى الآن.
سيباستيان سي إن إن في دوكسفورد بإنجلترا